ايران ترسل واطباء الى لبنان لمعالجه
الزعيم ميليشيا حزب الله
اعتذاره الاعلاميين بعد سوره التطبيل عشاق
الاسطوره بلا يلقون نظره الوداع الاخيره
عليه هذه الاخبار وغيرها منقولها لكم من
قناه العربيه انا ميسون عزام احييكم اهلا
بكم
عند دخوله المستشفى مؤخرا كشفت تقارير ان
ايران ارسلت عددا من الاطباء الى لبنان
لمعالجه الزعيم ميليشيا حزب الله حسن نصر
الله صحيفه تاتيهان الايرانيه المعارضه
نقلت عن موظفي مطار بيروت قولهم ان عدد من
الاشخاص يرتدون زيا خاصا بالاطباء ارسلوا
من طهران الى العاصمه اللبنانيه علمتني
طائره شركه معراج للطيران التابعه للحرس
الثوري وفيما قال بيان الحزب انه نصر الله
اصيب بالانفلونزا اكدت صحيفه الجرس
الاسرائيليه نقله الى العنايه المركزه بعد
اصابته بجلطه دماغيه
وبعد السجل الذي دخل فيه مع عدد من
الاعلاميين اسره تعليقه على صوره التطبيل
نفى رجل الاعمال المصري نجيب ساويرس انباء
متداوله حول اعتذاره منهم احد المغردين
وجه سؤال لسوارس عبرات تويتر حول رايه في
نبا عن اعتذاره للاعلاميين خلال حفل خاص
في الجونه ليرد سوارس قائلا كلام فارغ
فيما كان الاخير قد دخل الاسبوع الماضي في
سجال مع اعلاميين مصريين ابرزهم عمرو اديب
بعد تعليقه على صوره معدله وساخره لهم وهم
يدقون طبول في اشاره لكلمه التطبيل التي
يستخدمها مصريون لاتهام الاعلاميين
بالمبالغه في دعم وتاييد النظام
بعد وصول جسمانه الى ملعب نادي سانتوس
لكره القدم احتشد البرازيليون لتوديع
اسطوره كره القدم اتسون رنتيس دو ناسيمنتو
المعروف باسم بيليه عبر القائي نظره
الوداع الاخيره على جثمانه وسائل الاعلام
محليه كشفت ان جثمان بيليه سيظل في الملعب
الذي شهد انطلاقته نحو النجوميه حتى صباح
الثلاثاء ثم يحمل الجثمان في موكب عبر
شوارع مدينه سانتوس بما في ذلك المرور في
الشارع الذي تعيش فيه والدته فيليه الى ان
يصل لمثواه الاخير حيث ستقام جنازه خاصه
مخصصه لافراد الاسره
وجه البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو رساله
الى جماهير نادي النصر السعودي الذي يستعد
لاستقباله على ملعب مرسول بارك في العاصمه
الرياض غدا الثلاثاء وعلى متن طائره التي
تقله الى العاصمه السعوديه قالت دون في
مقطع فيديو عبر صفحته في انستغرام وجها
حديثه لجماهير النصر مرحبا يا رفاق اراكم
قريبا كان النادي السعودي اعلن ضم
كريستيانو الجمعه الماضي اذ وقع عقدا
رسميا مع النجم البرتغالي ليلعب بقميص
النادي الملقب بالعالمي لمده موسمين حتى
العام 20 25
[موسيقى]
وفي خبرنا الاخير اعتقلت السلطات الامنيه
في الجزائر العاصمه اعتقلت المؤثره على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وملكه جمال جمال
افريقيا السابقه وحيده قروج ليله راس
السنه وسائل اعلام محليه افادت بان القبض
على قروج تم بعد اقتحام منزلها والعثور
على كميه كبيره من مخدر الكوكايين اضافه
الى مبالغ ماليه ضخمه واوضحت مصادر رسميه
ان زوج المتهمه والذي كان خارج المنزل
لحظه اقتحام قد تفر بعد علمه بخبر اعتقال
زوجته
[موسيقى]